good morning believe nation today's
message is chemistry is everything over
to you Jennifer Lopez at the end of the
day we shall entrepreneur you're talking
about a creative visionary it's like
when somebody leaves the farm to the
business tool everything menu you're
smart enough to grab this person to the
great at marketing but this person who
is great at you know all the different
aspects of what you'll need to meet
whatever it is your business is to
succeed I always say chemistry is
everything you know you have to find
chemistry with people and and the people
that you have to have to do with it
doesn't always work that first person
that you choose but that jobs like come
in you just happens we're together I
would let me enough to have a lot of
people like that in my life because I'm
a Leo and very loyal I stay with those
people and where I go to build a
building building they can create
discover it and keep challenging
ourselves to be better better better and
what else what other product great
product because we create what are the
things can we do or the audience that's
watching I think this is a super
important message for entrepreneurs
because you need to be able to build
beyond yourself right you cannot do
everything alone it's just not possible
if you want to do something big you have
to bring on a team and one of the most
important things that you have to look
for is people that you have a good vibe
with people that you get along with
people that you can rip off of each
other I always look for people who Wow
me you know in my hiring process I will
I think the hiring process is broken I
think that too many people look at
resumes and cover letters and then by
the time you get to the point where you
get down to that last you know two or
three people you basically have to make
a decision based on those two because
you don't want to complete that whole
long terrible process all over again
where somebody's ability to write a
cover letter or do well in an interview
or have a good-looking resume has little
to do with the actual job that they're
gonna do where for me my hard process is
is completely different I've made videos
on it one of the most important parts of
my hiring process is I will bring on a
lot of people on a trial job I'll give
people something that I think will take
two hours of work and then I pay them as
a maximum of five hours to see how well
they do and one of the most important
things I'm looking for is how well do
they work with me how well do they wow
me how well are they over deliver what I
was looking for and those are the people
that you want to hold onto and build a
business around I've taken people who
work on my website like ray from the
Philippines and people who work on my
YouTube channel like Ivan and Kristina
and Jason and these are people who have
wowed me every step along the way where
I've tried are the people out before
them and we get along really well
together and that that's what allows us
to create really special things and so
you don't want to just look for people
who have the technical skills that you
need if you're looking to redevelop your
website you don't just need any
programmer because there's tons of
programmers out there you want somebody
who believes in your mission you want
somebody who you can have a coffee with
and get new ID
and get excitement and energy from and
if that's missing then I would strongly
encourage you to look for somebody else
don't settle for someone who's just good
enough continue looking for somebody
great so the question of the day today
is do you have great people around you
who you have amazing chemistry with
leave it in the comments below I'm gonna
join in the discussion thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso